how does your beauty routine change
since becoming a mom and doing
everything one-handed in two minutes
there's been a lot of nights that I've
fallen asleep with makeup on which I
never used to do and I will still wear
it the next morning she's really hot
right I've never used to do that that's
the one thing that I'm I'm like oh how
did this happen but it is mom life is
juggling act but just learning how to
you know put some highlighter on and
highlighters a little distracting so
even if you have a breakout you're like
okay don't type or concealer and giving
your daughter some makeup brushes goes a
long way I learned that I'm like okay
you're good right okay this is what I
was gonna ask you you know is is true
when is she playing with your makeup yet
she's still not quite there no she's
nine months she's playing with my makeup
just know what she's doing
heard that mom she was she is she was
playing with highlighter earlier today I
was like I don't know this is okay but
it's it's getting me to finish getting
dressed today so clean her up later but
she looks really good sparkly eat she
caught up with Chloe and her real-life
bestie Malika Haqq while promoting their
limited-edition Becca BFFs collection
with Becca cosmetics I've really trusted
them with perfecting the formulas and
they're so good at that but Malika and I
were really adamant about our colors and
our shades and Becca's such an easy
collaboration because they allowed us to
still be very us and we picked our names
and but we trusted them with what is the
best formulas
[Music]